yeah in the wake of this [ __ ] movie
released weekend I'm gonna take this
opportunity to review a movie that was
actually good that came out last year
that got a wider release this year and
then I was able to watch it in 2015
using the imitation game so the
imitation game takes place in world war
two stars Benedict Cumberbatch as
mathematician Alan Turing and the
Germans the Nazis they have this machine
called enigma it's this code machine
it's uncrackable no one knows how to
crack it's like the fate of the free
world's the key to defeating the Nazis
is cracking this code problem is this
code resets every day so anytime someone
gets close to possibly cracking it or
cracks a couple messages boom the code
is now new the next day all that works
is gone so Cumberbatch is like well let
me try to crack it and you'll know if
it's uncrackable Cumberbatch gets this
idea he's like what if I can build a
machine that adapts to code and it can
crack every code that enigma ever does
forever and that's ultimately the movie
it's just next-level [ __ ] in terms of
genius and I love this movie for that I
love stories like that I okay the acting
in this movie first of all fantastic
Benedict Cumberbatch is awesome I've
been a fan of this guy for a while you
guys know that it is what it is but
surprisingly Keira Knightley is great in
this movie too she's really good we saw
Keira Knightley is that attractive girl
who's completely functional in her movie
sure this made me go jab put her and
more stuff I love movies that are
intense and intriguing without action
without a lot of things that like that's
why I liked Argo Argo is most intense
movie without a shot fired I've ever
seen
that's this movie the thing is
everyone's like I don't know what you're
building but it's useless and he's like
eight will work you don't understand
it's just frustrating to see this genius
who knows what he's trying to do try to
explain to you know us common folk what
he's trying to do in a world where that
[ __ ] didn't exist it's not like oh this
machine exists I'll make it a little
better he was like this is it's just new
this is the first then you will have
machines like this later down the road
you'll look back and go oh it started
here I have to be the one that just
conjures this out of nothing now and
it's so great I love the fact that this
ultimately is telling us the untold
story that we never knew I didn't know
who Alan Turing was but what he was
doing in this movie is arguably the most
important thing that was
happening in World War two to beat the
Nazis we all know about Patton we all
know about Normandy no one knows about
this guy everybody should
so the imitation game had great acting
great characters their work was
intriguing
it was great like I love seeing
mathematicians do the thing they bring
it on the level where you're like I know
what you're doing and oh my god why
don't they understand they're just being
dicks right now but if you were in that
room and you had their job you'd be
yelling out of do be like who doesn't
work what do you do you're wasting our
time and money this is the story of a
lonely genius who is single-handedly
doing a very important piece in the COG
that is the wheel of taking on the Nazis
ultimately the biggest frustration in
the imitation game for me has nothing to
do with the movie it's marketing it
frustrates me that this movie ultimately
came out in January but it was a limited
release smaller movie in December so
it's a December movie didn't come out
anywhere near me in December so now I
had to wait till January to watch it and
it just gets a wider release that it
just I should have been able to see the
imitation game in 2014 that way it would
have been on my top 10 list of 2014
because the imitation game is awesome
tacular
I love seeing people go up against
impossible odds this guy is the one who
did it everyone should know who he is
now you can do the imitation game have
you seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you liked what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more